taratata benvenuti alla mia vita di
merda
oggi vi racconto di una cosa di cui non
vado fiero per niente neanche i miei
genitori infatti si stanno chiedendo
come facesse la loro figlio ma quello da
sempre oggi vi parlo del fatto che ho
perso la carta di identità tre volte in
un solo mese ragazzi sembra sembra che
io me li stia inventando ste cose per
fare clic based
ragazzi io vi giuro su questa serie come
avete visto parlo solo di cose che
realmente accadono e che realmente penso
quindi se ve lo sto dicendo vi giuro che
così vi darò anche le prove fine video
se riesco a buttarla dentro ma allora
anche cominciato all'inizio di
quest'anno gennaio per il 19 mi viene
regalato per natale un portafoglio molto
termino non dico la marca se non si
fanno prodotti placement gratis
li vogliamo fare ci metto dentro
ovviamente la mia carta di credito la
mia carta d'identità questo il 25
dicembre perché erano sale ok inizia
l'anno
siamo a gennaio circa il 4 o 5 gennaio
io perdo il portafoglio cioè quel
portafoglio a me durato dieci giorni io
il mio vecchio portafoglio collocavo
prima mi è durato tipo 10 anni e uso
sempre quello perché torniamo ancora una
volta sul discorso della turchia gina
cioè di calvin klein nel mio portafoglio
quindi è normale che lo tenga per dieci
anni perché mia mamma avrò speso un
sacco di soldi ai tempi e quindi ci
mancherebbe che io non lo sfrutti quel
portafoglio chi me lo guarda dice che il
logo roma logora sala la tua anima
brutto strano quindi mi è stato regalato
questo nuovo portafoglio ho iniziato a
usare quello prendo un car sharing a
milano ovviamente non guidavo io perché
c'è la patente da valona al brusco
arrivato a casa mi league mi rendo conto
di non avere il portafoglio guarin con
ho perso il portafoglio poi non è tanto
per i soldi perché a fine c'è un 20 euro
dentro
figurati se giro con più di 20 euro in
tanti ma stai scherzando
non è tanto per i soldi era per il
portafoglio in sé e per la carta di
identità ragazzi di fare un documento è
un dito nell'anno anzi sono due dita
nella quindi io non potevo mai pensare
aver perso un documento invece son
riuscito a perdere
vabbè è successo che ti devo dire quel
portafoglio era maledetto non potevo
tenerlo e dai una volta che succedono
era mai successo con succedere entro dai
carabinieri
buongiorno ho perso la carta d'identità
quando tu perdi un documento diventare
il 40 carabinieri fare la denuncia
perché se no non lo puoi rifare dove hai
persa e l'ho persa in un car sharing
insomma hai chiamato per vedere se c'era
nel sedile dietro che pagare
sì ho provato se mai chiamato così ho
provato hai provato a chiedere la
persona che era con te se l'avessi io ho
provato gli non c'è la carta d'identità
facciamo una denuncia le denunce non
servono teoricamente alla sega non è che
t'ha ritrovano nei grandi in giro a
cercare se c'è la carta d'identità
teoricamente il 99,99 99 per cento delle
volte in cui fai una denuncia i cui
verso un documento non lo ritrovi mai
serve solo per per rifarla indovinate un
po un giorno vi arriva una chiamata
signora ostuni sì abbiamo trovato il suo
portafoglio con la carta d'identità
dentro dio esiste questa ne è la prova
per dire questa cagata ho preso gol vado
lì grazie grazie mille deve pagare 5
euro
tieni sono tirchio ma tieni dotato di 5
euro mi hanno ridato il mio portafoglio
bellissimo che era un regalo è la
persona che mi aveva regalato ci deve
anche tanto quindi mi piaceva anche
tanto per quello oltre che per la carta
tutto bene passano sette giorni più o
meno e vado a fare l'esame della patente
del mio settimo immagino vado a fare un
esame della patente per fare l'esame la
patente devi dare la carta d'identità
devi far vedere che istituti di l'area
teti da sono io sto facendo le dava
faccio l'esame mi promuovo non è vero
sto scherzando
torno a casa mentre sto tornando a casa
mi sono iniziate una piccola
particolarità scusate mi sono molto
importante quando tu ritrovi la carta
d'identità devi tornare dai carabinieri
e fa e dire l'ho trovata ok di ritorni
al carabinieri dire ho trovato la
caratteristica così loro tolgono la
denuncia dal loro database e io non
l'avevo ancora fatto perché la passato
pochissimo da quando lavori trovata sarà
insomma sto per tornare a casa
manca veramente poco che sono andato a
fare la parente lontano da
perché a milano purtroppo non la posso
fare se non mi riconoscono tutti mentre
sto facendo l'esame nonché fuori sia
diverso ma almeno un po meno mentre sto
per tornare a casa mi arriva una
chiamata faccio pronto salve siamo i
carabinieri
io dei carabinieri ci devo andare a
nozze non c'è verso so perché i
carabinieri mi chiamano mi chiamano più
loro che mia madre è impossibile salvo i
carabinieri non quelli di borgo d'oro
sono altri abbiamo trovato la sua carta
d'identità non lo guardi lo solo già
ritirata devo passare a a dirvi che l'ho
ritrovata celo celo giallo jaric cielo
già nel cielo qua perché io pensavo che
fossero i miei carabinieri quelli che a
cui avevo fatto la denuncia che ce ne
erano altri controllo tra le via
portafoglio e la mia catene titta non
c'era
gli dico stia fermo arrivo praticamente
mi sono rifatto tutto indietro arrivato
a casa
1 ora per ritornare di un'ora di
macchina andare e tornare lavoro fatto
quattro volte in un giorno c'è veramente
ero impazzito
sono arrivato lì e ho ritirato la mia
caratteristica perché mentre facevo
l'esame quando sono uscito bis caduta
per terra perché era in mezzo ai fogli
dell'esame ed era caduta per terra
loro avevano ancora nel database che la
mia carta d'identità era smarrita gli
risultava smarrita qui io sono andato lì
a dirgli no guarda che l'avevo già
ritrovata e lo risma rita di nuovo
capito eccolo lì non ci voleva credere
numero radar e poi non adatta perché ho
detto vabbè dai un deficiente trio
passano una decina di giorni ero in taxi
il taxi mi accompagna a casa vago con la
carta di credito militi con il
portafoglio lido la carta di credito
vago grazie riprendo la carta di credito
la metto nel portafoglio il portafoglio
lo metto in tasca e scola taxi ed è
implicato il giorno dopo deve uscire mi
sveglio faccio per prendere il
portafoglio sul comodino e non c'era
edicola come o impossibile l'omesso tua
guardo in giro tutto il tempo non
trovavo il mio portafoglio ma come ieri
ho pagato il taxi acqua fuori
morale della favola cosa è successo io
sono uscito dal taxi e nel tragitto taxi
casa mia che sono 15 m 15
io sono uscito dal taxi che ero davanti
alla porta di casa mi ha praticamente 15
dovevo fare il marciapiede e poi c'è la
casa mia
15 metri di tragitto io ho perso per la
terza volta la mia ho perso il
portafoglio per la seconda volta per la
terza volta la mia carta d'identità orco
demoni in quindici metri sono uscito di
casa ho guardato per terra ovunque non
c'era ovviamente quelli siano potuti
tutti non c'era neanche un euro in quel
portafoglio per ho riperso il
portafoglio che aveva regalato li
mortacci mia ho riperso il mio documento
porco demonio avevo appena fatto la
denuncia che ho ritrovato il documento e
niente praticamente riso dovuto
svegliare ho perso documento vado dai
carabinieri buongiorno giorno ancora tu
ciao lorenzo come stai bene per fammi
indovinare a carta d'identità bravissimo
giovanni ormai siamo pappa e ciccia di
rete in un mese di conosco più che mia
moglie
va bene farci di nuovo la denuncia per
la terza volta
tutto questo ragazzo ho visto veramente
tutti i carabinieri che la mia famiglia
in un mese non sto scherzando che stava
sembra sembra per esagerare ma non sto
scherzando ho rifatto la denuncia dei
carabinieri denuncia che ciò ancora
adesso faceva la carta identità ancora
adesso non c'è lo quindi facendo un
sunto delle mie disgrazie perdo il
portafoglio nella nella macchina
faccio la denuncia ho perso il
portafoglio melo ritrovano prima ancora
che io dice se i carabinieri che avranno
ritrovato lo riperso quindi mi chiamano
i carabinieri di un'altra regione
praticamente devo uscire di moda la
lombardia per andare figli perché se ne
sono accorti prima loro persa che io
vado fin lì la riprendo vado a togliere
la denuncia e come tolgo la denuncia al
tempo niente
si perde di nuovo il velo giorno ragazzi
si è inventato affermava non sto
scherzando è andata veramente così
all'ultimo secondo mai una gioia io ho
perso la vita tre volte ragazzi tra
l'altro è di quella quella di carta con
la vecchia quella che probabilmente non
avete neanche più voi perché ormai le
fanno tutti potessero a quelle che si
perdono ancora meglio
qui non vedo l'ora di avere la mia
nuovissima carta d'identità che adesso
devo andare a fare per perdere pure
quella incredibile no ragazzi di giovani
carabinieri sembrava che gli stessi
prentando ogni volta che andavo lì
dentro riguardavano venire ma sei scemo
eh sì questa la risposta
mia madre ho smesso di dirglielo che
l'ho persa dopo la prima volta anche se
non c'è veramente non mi avrebbe
diseredato come figlio però io veramente
ragazzi sto vivendo
un periodo buio la mia vita non ho un
documento praticamente cosa succede
quando tu non hai la carta d'identità
entri nei carabinieri tpc buongiorno
verso la carta identità va bene abbiamo
subito la pratica mi fornisca un
documento lo penso ok allora ci facciamo
questo foglio bianco firmato che dove
c'è scritto che hai perso la capacità
così se ti ferma qualcuno li dai quello
e vale come caratteristiche ok io giro
con quel foglio che un foglio normale
piegato nel portafoglio quello vecchio
logo di calvin klein col numero perdo
mai lo tengo lì dentro e poi vale come
carta d'identità cielo da da gennaio ei
ragazzi il discorso è questo io oi nata
tutto questo l'ho fatto io che l'ho
persa 3 volte perché non volevo
abbandonare il portafoglio di kevin
kline vecchio e logoro lo facesse il mio
portafoglio di kevin kline casa pepsi
però fa niente l'importante sia il milan
regalato non spendo soldi per loeb è di
marca però importante la denuncia dei
carabinieri attuale la terza ovviamente
però viene sia piaciuto se trovate la
mia carta in giro chiamatemi per
cortesia
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo come sempre
ad un prossimo video beh ragazzi bella
dei carabinieri
[Musica]